FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP BLASTING SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI JUST MOMENTS AGO
FOR CANCELING THE STATE OF THE
UNION HE WAS PLANNING TO DELIVER
ON THE HOUSE CHAMBER ON TUESDAY.
>> OF THE STATE OF THE UNION
SPEECH HAS BEEN CANCELED BY
NANCY PELOSI BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO HEAR THE TRUTH.
SHE DOESN'T WANT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC TO HEAR WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND SHE'S AFRAID OF THE TRUTH.
WE ARE PLANNING ON DOING A
REALLY VERY IMPORTANT SPEECH IN
FRONT OF THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE, SUPREME COURT.
WE FOUND OUT SHE'S CANCELED IT
AND I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
BLOTCH ON THE INCREDIBLE COUNTRY
THAT WE ALL LOVE.
SHE BLAMES A SECURITY, BUT SHE
KNEW IT WASN'T A SECURITY
PROBLEM.
I JUST GOT BACK FROM IRAQ.
I WAS VERY SAFE IN IRAQ AND I
FEEL VERY SAFE.
WE HAD GREAT, GREAT SECURITY.
IF WE CAN HANDLE IRAQ, WE CAN
HANDLE WASHINGTON.
WE'LL DO SOMETHING IN THE
ALTERNATIVE, AND WE WILL BLEED
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT THAT AT A
LATER DATE.
WHAT SHE IS DOING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHAT SHE'S
DOING TO OUR CONSTITUTION IS A
DISGRACE.
>> Jesse: WHAT WAS THAT MOVIE,
GREG?
YOU CAN'T HANDLE THE TRUTH.
>> Greg: YES, JERRY MAGUIRE.
I'M KIDDING.
I KNOW.
I'M JOKING.
ARE YOU ASKING YOUR QUESTION?
>> Jesse: I AM TEEING YOU UP.
>> Greg: I AM ECSTATIC THIS IS
COMING TOGETHER.
I DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO D.C.
D.C. IS THE WORST RIDE IN
AMERICA'S AMUSEMENT PARK.
THERE IS NO FUN IN D.C., JUST
WALKING TOURS.
THE MOST OVERRATED CAPITAL IN
AMERICA, AND I INCLUDE
SACRAMENTO IN THAT.
DONALD TRUMP HAS DISRUPTED AND
GOTTEN OFF OUR PLATE.
LAST YEAR WAS THE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER.
WE DIDN'T NEED THAT.
WE DON'T MISS IT.
WERE NOT GOING TO MISS THE STATE
OF THE UNION.
HE SHOULD DO IT IN SKY WRITING.
HE SHOULD SKY WRITE HIS STATE OF
THE UNION.
OR HE SHOULD DO IT IN A TWITTER
THREAD.
THAT'S EASY TOO.
YOU DON'T NEED THIS STUPID POMP
AND CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> Jesse: WHAT WOULD THE SKY
WRITING SAY?
BUILD THE WALL AND CRIME WILL
FALL?
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
HE'S GOTTEN RID OF THE
CORRESPONDENCE DINNER.
STATE OF THE UNION.
I THINK HE SHOULD GET RID OF
STUBBORN BELLY FAT AND
EMBARRASSING BACK FAT.
THOSE PILLS THAT COME IN PALMS
THAT YOU CAN OPEN.
GET RID OF THAT.
TMV, GET RID OF THAT.
WE ARE DONE.
>> Jesse: WHAT IS TMV?
>> Greg: DMV.
>> Jesse: DON'T GET RID OF
DMZ.
WE LOVE IT.
IT'S A BLOTCH.
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
HE HAS CHECKED IT OUT.
HE WAS SAYING THAT HE WAS SAFE
IN IRAQ.
>> Dana: I ALWAYS THOUGHT
NANCY PELOSI HAD A STRONGER
ARGUMENT, WERE NOT DOING IT
UNTIL THE GOVERNMENT IS BACK
OPEN.
WE WILL INVITE YOU DOWN.
SHE IS STILL KIND OF SAYING THAT
BUT HER FIRST LETTER SAID PLEASE
DON'T GIVE A STATE OF THE UNION
ON JANUARY 29.
THE SECOND ONES THAT I THINK IT
WOULD NOT BE A GOOD IDEA BECAUSE
OF SECURITY CONCERNS.
HE WAS RIGHT THAT THAT IS LAME.
SECURITY CONCERNS ARE NOT REAL.
SHE WOULD BE STRONGER TO SAY WE
ARE NOT DOING THIS UNTIL THE
GOVERNMENT IS REOPENED.
THE PEOPLE DESERVE TO BE PAID
FOR THE WORK THEY ARE DOING.
WHEN THAT IS DONE, YOU CAN COME
BACK.
>> Jesse: SHE SENT THE FIRST
LETTER DURING THE SHUTDOWN.
PRESIDENT IS SAYING WHY ARE
USING THIS AS AN EXCUSE WHEN YOU
INVITED ME DURING THE SHUTDOWN
IN THE BEGINNING?
>> Juan: I DON'T BUY THE
SECURITY THING AT ALL.
BUT CLEARLY THE GOVERNMENT DOES
NOT FUNCTIONING.
THERE ARE REAL ISSUES AT PLAY.
YOU STOP AND LOOK AT IT, I THINK
IT'S 800,000 NOT BEING PAID TO
CONTRACTORS.
TODAY WE HEARD ABOUT IRS AGENTS
WHO ARE NOT REPORTING BUT
GETTING PASSES SO THEY CAN GO
OUT AND GET SMALL JOBS TO HELP
PAY THE BILLS.
FBI SAYS CHILD TRAFFICKING,
TERROR INVESTIGATIONS ARE BEING
IMPEDED, ACCORDING TO THE FBI
UNION.
THE AIRPORTS, WE KNOW ABOUT.
THE COAST GUARD WE KNOW ABOUT.
TO ME, THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS THEY
WERE GOING TO HAVE A CONFERENCE
ON BORDER SECURITY AND THEY
CAN'T HAVE THAT.
SENATOR MARK WARNER SAID STOP
STUPIDITY.
STOP INFLICTING SHUTDOWN,
TRANSFERRING UNNECESSARY PAIN
AND INFLICTING DAMAGE AND YOU
SEE THIS IN THE POLLS.
71% OF AMERICANS SAY THIS WALL
IS NOT WORTH THE SHUTDOWN.
THIS IS HURTING THE COUNTRY.
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME, IT IS
HURTING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD BE
THRILLED.
JUAN I'M NOT THRILLED.
I'M KIND OF SAD THE COUNTRIES IN
THIS PLACE.
>> Jedediah: IF THIS IS ALL
HAPPENING, WHY DON'T DEMOCRATS
GET ON BOARD AND SUPPORT THE
STUFF THEY SUPPORTED YEARS AGO
THAT HE IS PROPOSING.
THEY ARE ON RECORD AS HAVING
SUPPORTED NOT ONLY BORDER
SECURITY MEASUREMENTS BUT NOW
THEY'RE SAYING NO, WE DON'T WANT
HUMANITARIAN AID OR DACA
RECIPIENTS.
THESE THINGS ARE BAD BUT HE PUT
FORWARD SOMETHING COMPLETELY
PALATABLE.
NANCY PELOSI IS A SPITEFUL ONE
SOMETIMES.
SHE IS.
SHE DIDN'T WANT TRUMP TO COME
OUT.
I DON'T LOVE THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
I AGREE WITH GREG.
I THINK IT'S BORING.
I THINK SOMEHOW THEY MAKE
PRESIDENTS LOOK LIKE MONARCHS.
IT'S PAINFUL TO WATCH.
BUT IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
OUT THERE AND HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE TUNE IN TO SOMETHING
WHICH TYPICALLY THEY WOULDN'T TO
AN END AND I DON'T THINK SHE
WANTED PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT THE ASPECTS OF CRIME AND
THE FACT THAT HE PUT FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAD THAT DACA
RELIEF IN THE TPS RELIEF SO THAT
VOTERS COULD SAY HE DID PUT
SOMETHING FORTH THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN PALATABLE.
WISE AND SHE BITING?
>> Dana: HE GAVE A PRIME TIME
ADDRESS LAYING OUT THOSE THINGS
EXCEPT FOR THE STUFF THAT HE
OFFERED ON SATURDAY.
HE DIDN'T MOVE THE NEEDLE AT
ALL.
AGAINST HER.
IF SHE'S JUST BEING POLITICALLY
SMART -- I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
GOOD POLICY.
BEING POLITICALLY SMART, WHY
WOULD YOU MOVE?
>> Jedediah: THAT'S TRUE BUT I
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT TUNE
IN.
I WATCH NEWS ALL THE TIME.
I KNOW PEOPLE WHO DON'T WATCH
NEWS A LOT.
BUT THE STATE OF THE UNION, THEY
WILL.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE NO CHOICE.
IT'S ON EVERY CHANNEL.
>> Juan: YOU COULD READ A BOOK
IF YOU WANT.
>> Greg: ACTUALLY DO READ
BOOKS, JUAN.
>> Juan: WHEN YOU SEE THIS
ARGUMENT ABOUT CRIME IN THE WALL
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS TWEETING
ABOUT TODAY, IT IS SO
FALLACIOUS.
THE STATISTICS SAY VIOLENT CRIME
HAS BEEN DOWN OVER THE LAST 20
YEARS, EVEN AS WE HAVE SEEN THE
INCREASE IN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> Jedediah: WHY HAVE BEEN
DEMOCRATS BEEN CALLING IT A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
>> Jesse: WHEN THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A WALL IN EL PASO, THERE
WAS A LOT OF VIOLENT CRIME.
THEY PUT THE WALL UP AND CRIME
DROPPED.
LET'S LISTEN TO CHUCK ABOUT THIS
WHOLE HOSTAGETAKING SCENARIO.
>> Greg: OR NOT.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S PROPOSAL IS
JUST WRAPPING PAPER ON THE SAME
PARTISAN PACKAGE AND
HOSTAGETAKING.
>> HOSTAGETAKING SHOULD NOT
WORK.
IT'S VERY HARD TO NEGOTIATE WHEN
A GUN IS HELD TO YOUR HEAD.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SHUTDOWN AND NOW THEY
HAVE LEARNED THAT LEADER
McCONNELL IS A COCONSPIRATOR.
>> Jesse: THE
PRESIDENT ACTUALLY CALLED
CHUCK SCHUMER A PUPPET OF
PELOSI.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S TRYING TO DRIVE
A WEDGE BETWEEN THE TWO LEADERS.
>> Greg: TO USE HIS ANALOGY,
THOUGH, AMERICANS HAVE BEEN HELD
HOSTAGE BY CAREER POLITICIANS
WHO MAKE A NICE LIVING OFF THIS
PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
THEY NEED US TO BE POLARIZED ON
IMMIGRATION.
THEY NEED YOU TO THINK THAT
HAVING A WALL MEANS YOU DON'T
LIKE PEOPLE FROM MEXICO.
THEY NEED THAT ARGUMENT BECAUSE
IT KEEPS THEM IN POWER.
THERE HAS TO BE A WAY OF
BREAKING OUT OF THIS PRISON
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T BE PRO-REFUGEE
BUT ALSO MAYBE YOU SHOULD LIMIT
MERIT BASED IMMIGRATION.
I AM MORE INCLINED TO GO WITH
REFUGEES THEN MERIT-BASED
BECAUSE REFUGEES ARE MORE
GRATEFUL.
BUT YOU CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
COMPROMISE.
GET OUT OF THIS PRISON.
WHEN REFUGEES COME HERE, THEY
MAKE GREAT CITIZENS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO EXTREME EVENT.
THE COMPROMISE HERE IS HAVING A
NUMBER OF TOOLS IN THE SHED.
IT'S NOT JUST THIS OR THIS.
THAT'S THE PRISON.
YOU HAVE TO FIND THESE OTHER
TOOLS.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF DIFFERENT
CLUBS IN THE BAG.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Juan: IT SOUNDED LIKE YOU
WERE DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING.
>> Jesse: DON'T YOU DARE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE RIGHT.
WHERE ARE THE DEMOCRATS?
>> Juan: THE DEMOCRATS --
>> Greg: WHY AREN'T THEY
COMING FORWARD?
>> Juan: THEY HAVE BUT
McCONNELL WON'T BRING IT
FORWARD.
>> Dana: HE WON'T BRING IT
FORWARD BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
WON'T SIGN IT.
>> Juan: IT'S LIKE A TRAP.
YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF THE TRAP.
POOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, STUCK IN